Let's go to Alex from Orange County, Alex
from Orange County. You're on the air.
A David Pakman hearing. Yes, I can.
Awesome, so I remember you said every
midterm election, if the president wins, the
opposing sides also win. Why do you think that?
No, no, no, that's that's not always the case.
But that's it's often the case. Not always.
OK, is there a reason why that happens
to people just stay home and assume we're
all good or something like that?
Yeah, I think it's a combination
of things. So I think when when you have
one party, when a presidential election
and then you have a midterm two years later,
there's a couple of different things that
are going on. One, in general, there's a lower
turnout in midterms than there is in presidential
elections. So by its very nature, that means that
whoever is more motivated in the midterm has a
better shot at being able to turn the election
in their favor. And what motivates people to get
out and vote? Well, it's their opponent winning.
So when you see one party win in a presidential,
it will often be more motivational
to the opponents of that person,
to the members of the party that is in
opposition to the winner of the White House.
And so you'll see them come out in larger numbers
in the following midterms. That's typically the
way it goes. I don't know that that's the
way twenty, twenty two will go, though.
OK, can I ask you one more thing? Of course.
After the 2020 elections, do you trust
polling data at all, even though, like it really
felt like Joe Biden really had this in the bag,
but we were all pretty nervous, you
know, when Election Day happened?
I mean, listen, the the not the polling data
certainly was skewed more in the Biden direction
than what ended up being the actual outcome. Now,
Joe Biden was projected to win the popular vote
and he did. And Joe Biden was projected to win the
electoral vote and he did. But there's no denying
that the margin was not what many expected
it to be, including in states like Wisconsin
as an example. So, you know, the trusting
polling data is very black and white. I
think we have to understand the limitations of
polling, but at the same time understand that
it's it is not as precise, precise as many of us
would want. And as I spoke about with David Shore
not long ago, he pointed out that the idea
of we now have such politicization of polling
that there are certain populations that will
respond to polling in a certain way and that
can skew the results. We have to be we have
to account for that. That's a real thing.
OK, well, we all do, and thank you for taking my
call. My pleasure. Great to hear from you. Really
appreciate it. And then why don't we talk to.
How about we speak to Antonioni from Chicago?
I hope I'm pronouncing that correctly.
Hey, can you hear me, David?
Yes, I can, yeah, no, that's that's correct.
Pronunciation, love it. Big fan of the show.
Thanks for taking the call. Thank you,
most of what I have to ask is about
covid relief and budget reconciliation, OK, a kind
of OK, so I guess I need to refresh a little bit
on the current. Current status in the next action
step, so. Right now, we're trying to pass covid
relief through budget reconciliation,
which that passed the House, correct.
Yes, it did. You know, now you have me
doubting where it stands right now. Yeah. Yes.
I didn't mean to put you on the spot here because
I realize there's so much going on and there is
always a new update. So, like, if you don't know
one of these questions, like, I totally get it.
Yeah, no, I'm not up to speed
up to it. I know that Democrats
believe they need to move forward without
Republicans and that that clearly is the case. I
actually am unsure where the bill is right now.
Yeah, I don't know if it passed the House. No,
because I thought it did. And then there was
still debate, you know, about the income threshold
that who's going to get the you know, the relief?
Indeed. I was like, OK, maybe it didn't pass the
House anyway. So I guess what I'm going to do is I
really wanted to know your opinion on do you think
reoccurring relief is even going to be a thing
or is this going to be one of the I mean,
if you had to guess, I know it's really hard or
in a pandemic, you don't know how this is going
to play out, but we'll see how long this process
takes. And if I guess it's not too long, you know,
it's expectable has been a month since Biden came
into office. But as for that, fourteen hundred,
you know, there's some progress is fighting for
two thousand dollars reoccurring and I just don't
like how long it's like what's going to be
the process for that? Because I know we have
to get this. Fourteen hundred. Yeah. Through
through budget reconciliation. So what would
the process then be to get another two thousand.
You're exactly right. I hate to rain on anybody's
parade. I don't think recurring payments are going
to happen. And there are people that love the idea
of sort of like pandemic basic income. In a sense,
if things particularly as you're pointing out,
it's a lot of work just to get this. Fourteen
hundred dollars done. And I hope that we start
to recover from the pandemic both from a health
standpoint and an economic standpoint. And if
that happens, I don't know. I don't even think
that you're going to have Republican Democrats
in the Senate going for recurring payments. So
I want to be as real with the audience as I can.
I don't see it. I don't see it happening.
I don't see you then. And I agree. And I guess
one of the last questions has to do with this is
there's there's all this talk about, you know,
there's a lot of Democrats were fighting to
lower that threshold to 50 K. Yes. For the relief
doing who who are they? Because Joe
Manchin is kind of like, you know,
the mascot for them. But I don't know who
the other ones are. And I guess they're not.
They're going anonymous that seem to be with the
issue is I don't have the list in front of me, but
this is exactly what we were talking about when
Joe Biden won, where we were saying, you know,
if we're assuming everything will be 50 50 and
then Comilla gets it through, we're forgetting
that there are occasionally Democrats who don't
just sign their names to what Joe Biden wants or
what the bulk of the Democrats in the Senate want.
And we are seeing that, yeah, I'm a get obviously.
I just I don't know that it needs to be said I'm
against lowering the threshold to fifty thousand.
Yeah, OK, I mean, that's it, and I you know, I
hope I saw how the Komala was interviewing with,
you know, the newspaper with Joe Manchin from or
whatever, trying to push him to get that through.
And I. I hope there's more tactics like that to
push these people that are more center to the
left and this time certainly. Awesome. Thanks
so much for taking the call. I appreciate it.
All right. Antonioni from Chicago, great to
hear from you. We're going to go to a break.
Sorry I wasn't able to get to everybody. I
do my best, but I can never get to everybody.
There's always more. We will
take a quick break and be back
with more right after this. The David
Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.